The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
RIK EBERHARDT: OK.
So the way to this day
is going to be set up
is we've got one hour to
go Philip, me, and Drew.
We'll go to each
team, and we're just
going to talk with each team
about your updated vision
statement-- you should
have one by now--
your product backlog
you just turned in,
and your sprint tasklist
you just turned in.
The main thing we
want to talk about
is just some more
detailed discussion
based on the presentations
you gave, as well.
So what are you doing over
the next week and a half?
What do we think the
biggest issues are?
What are your plans for
Thanksgiving, and not working
during Thanksgiving, hopefully?
And we'll go in that order--
so Heat Wave, Hello Wave, Snap,
Cholera, and Awesome Cholera.
It should only take about
five to 10 minutes per team,
unless you have more questions.
And then after that, you
are free to depart or work
in class.
We've got the room
until 4:00, as well.
Before we do that, Phillip
had some generalized feedback
he wanted to give.
PHILLIP TAN: So after
looking through all
of the state of the projects
in terms of the deliverables
that you handed us, when we
looked through the product
backlogs, we noticed
something fairly consistent
among all the teams.
And that was you know how you
have these columns, right?
You have your serial
number, your item number
of your task, the
description of the task,
usually who it's assigned
to, and then a priority list.
Well, first of all,
everybody sent us
this list sorted by serial
number rather than my priority
list.
That's not so bad,
because we can always just
resort it ourselves.
The problem was that the
priorities was something
like, task one was priority one.
Task two was priority one.
Task three was priority one.
Task four was priority one.
Task five was priority two.
And then it goes, two, two, two,
two, two, three, three, three,
three, three.
And that-- if you get granular
enough, that might be fine.
But I'm a little
bit worried that's
not quite granular
enough when it
comes to your priority levels.
Everybody seems to have
about three to four levels
of priority.
And you get these
huge swaths of tasks
that all have the same priority.
So you don't actually know
which one's more important.
Now, you might be
thinking, well,
they're all assigned
to different people.
So for everybody who
has a set of tasks,
they have a priority
one task and they
know what they're supposed
to be doing right away.
And that's true
for the individual.
The problem is that
if you've got--
I'm just going to bring this up.
If you've got-- OK.
So say this-- what the?
Oh, here we go.
Say this is your
product backlog,
and you've got a chunk
of priority one tasks,
priority two tasks,
priority three tasks.
And each one of these
tasks have been assigned
to some individual person.
Maybe you've got something
like all your priority
one stuff done.
All that is cleared.
All the most important
things got done.
We are fine.
So now you're somewhere dealing
with all of your priority two
tasks.
And some of them are done.
Some of them are not done.
Hopefully you're finishing
off a priority two task
before you get to your
priority three tasks.
And so this is person
A, this is person B,
this is person C. And
person C's done their job.
Person B's done their job.
And person A's
still working on it.
How complete is
your game, actually?
Your game's only as
complete as person A
is capable of
finishing their task.
So if you've got like a
giant list of priorities--
if I were to take this list
of priority one, priority
two, priority three and
forced sat you down and went
through the arduous
process of actually giving
each individual task a
separate priority number
so that you could actually
solve it and rank it--
I'm going to do that.
Because I know it takes
a heck of a long time.
But if I were to do that,
what you'll find most likely
is that you've got a bunch
of tasks that are done.
You have an undone task, a
bunch of tasks that are done,
an undone task, and then some
stuff done, and a whole bunch
of undone tasks.
And the game's only this done.
You are not here.
You are here.
And you need to be able
to see that as a team.
You need to be able
to actually see,
what is the highest, most
important thing that's
still not completed?
Right now, at the
level of granularity
that we're looking at all
of your product backlogs,
all of your product
backlogs don't quite
have that level of granularity.
But, it is possible
that in your head,
you actually have that
level of granularity--
that you actually know in
your team what that highest
level undone task is,
even though they all
have the same priority.
They're all priority two
tasks, or something like that.
So something that will be useful
before you depart class today
is to actually figure out--
off all of the things that
are the highest
priority and undone
right now, what is really
the most important thing?
And who's responsible for that?
In fact, all of your
highest priority tasks
should all be
assigned to somebody.
And you should have a good
sense of what order of priority
they are.
Because not everybody
who's been assigned a task
is actually going to be
able to complete a task
before the next time you meet.
And the next time when you
meet, when you actually check in
and you discover
some tasks are done
and some tasks
haven't been done,
you need to know how much
progress your team actually
made towards
completion of the game.
Otherwise, you may say, oh, we
got five out of our six tasks--
only that one task
that didn't get done
turns out to be the most
important thing, which
means you actually haven't made
enough progress on your game
at all.
And you need to know that
so that you can actually
start to cut features, scope
down, and do all of the things
that we talked about regarding
crisis control for your team.
So we'll talk a little bit
more with each individual team
about that.
But that's a conversation
that you should
be having within your own team.
Of all your highest
priority tasks, which one's
actually the highest priority?
OK?
RIK EBERHARDT: All right.
So take a minute just to
meet up with your team,
and we're going to go to
Heat Wave in one minute.
Also, make sure you've got a
playable version of your game,
because Drew would
like to see it.
He was not available
for the presentations.
Amelia wanted Drew
to play, since he's
played it during the play test.
And there might have been
some stuff that changed.
ANDREW GRANT: Oh, excellent.
That person's on fire.
I like it already.
People are dying, and you're
asking me questions why?
Seriously?
You're dying, and
I'm talking to you.
Why are you talking
back when you're dying?
All right.
Cool.
PHILLIP TAN: So, I
just want to be clear.
Catching on fire is fainting?
AUDIENCE: Equivalent, yeah.
PHILLIP TAN: Yeah?
OK.
All right.
AUDIENCE: It's a metaphor.
AUDIENCE: It's meant to
invoke an emotional response.
PHILLIP TAN: Yes.
ANDREW GRANT: It does that.
Oh my god.
They're all dying.
[LAUGHTER]
Hello.
Go inside.
No.
OK.
AUDIENCE: Ah.
Something you should
know is the dialog
is just-- the back
end's working,
but we actually haven't
put the content in yet.
ANDREW GRANT: Sure.
OK.
AUDIENCE: The dialog will be
much more educational and--
AUDIENCE: And have choices,
which it currently doesn't.
ANDREW GRANT: OK.
Sure.
AUDIENCE: You guys
are going to want to--
AUDIENCE: So right now, we
don't have an and condition,
because the dialog is just--
ANDREW GRANT: Well,
you eventually will.
AUDIENCE: Yeah yeah.
ANDREW GRANT: It's currently
the Space Invadors style.
You will eventually
die and condition?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
ANDREW GRANT: OK, cool.
RIK EBERHARDT: So I've got
the old vision statement.
Did you make a new
version of that,
and is that on
Stellar right now?
AUDIENCE: No, it is not.
I didn't realize we needed it
for today, because it wasn't
on the homework assignments.
RIK EBERHARDT: Oh, yeah, yeah.
That's OK.
Then just--
AUDIENCE: I'll redo it today.
RIK EBERHARDT: OK, cool.
Yeah, that's-- I should
have put that on the thing.
AUDIENCE: In therms
of the task breakdown,
its' actually pretty
much the same.
And the overall vision I
haven't looked at in a while,
but I think most of
our goals are the same.
RIK EBERHARDT: Yeah.
It actually looks pretty--
so, like, vaguely,
when you're reading through
the old 30 of game play,
it feels like this game.
A lot of these
elements are in there.
AUDIENCE: We haven't
had any major design
changes in terms of that.
RIK EBERHARDT: OK.
So between Monday and
today, has anything new
gone on the chopping block?
Are any other
features getting cut?
AUDIENCE: Monday is when
the product backlog was due?
RIK EBERHARDT: Yeah.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: No.
We caught secondary scenes, and
everything else seemed doable,
because a lot of it-- the only
other thing that could possibly
be cut is items
breaking over time.
RIK EBERHARDT: Yep.
AUDIENCE: Everything else
is actually in progress,
and just being improved upon.
RIK EBERHARDT: OK.
AUDIENCE: So they
might not break.
It might be that once you've
installed an umbrella,
it will last forever, kind of
thing-- or a water fountain,
or whatever we choose.
But everything else
is in progress,
and I really think we're
on track to finishing OK.
RIK EBERHARDT: OK.
So you said a lot of the
content you have to get in
is the dialogue.
Then you're also going to
be doing some new artwork
for the characters.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
RIK EBERHARDT: Is Julia the only
person doing artwork on that?
AUDIENCE: She is the only
person doing artwork.
RIK EBERHARDT: Is she
also doing dialog?
AUDIENCE: No.
AUDIENCE: Uh, no.
AUDIENCE: I'm doing
the dialog content.
AUDIENCE: All the backup
stuff was for my UAP,
so I was kind of--
RIK EBERHARDT: OK.
But, I mean, are you
still coding the dialog
system for this game?
AUDIENCE: Not anymore.
AUDIENCE: Unless it's debugging.
RIK EBERHARDT: So you're
saying it's bug OK.
AUDIENCE: We need more testing.
We know that.
AUDIENCE: If there are
issues, I will fix them.
RIK EBERHARDT: That was
like the big red flag
when Phillip and I were
talking, is that one person
doing two important things.
AUDIENCE: We know
that there's-- no, no.
The dialog is split between
these two lovely people.
RIK EBERHARDT: Oh, yeah.
No, not the creation
of the dialog.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
RIK EBERHARDT: That's not the
thing we're concerned about.
It's the creation of
the art with one person,
and that person also
being the person in charge
of the back end for your dialog.
AUDIENCE: Oh, yeah.
The back end--
AUDIENCE: Well, I mean,
it was a lot of work,
but again, it's like I was
counting the dialog for my UAP
instead, so I was
definitely doing this fast.
It's not a big thing.
So the artwork is my,
like, contribution
for this project for this class.
RIK EBERHARDT: OK.
All right.
So if you have enough
time during the day
that if that breaks--
AUDIENCE: I do.
I can get the art done.
I know that.
RIK EBERHARDT: and
you're doing both.
OK.
All right.
We'll see how that goes.
AUDIENCE: Worst case,
we'll have stick figures.
It'll be OK.
RIK EBERHARDT: Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
And from our point
of view, it's fine.
ANDREW GRANT: These
people are fine.
RIK EBERHARDT: These
ANDREW GRANT:
Unless they don't--
AUDIENCE: The issue
with that is one
of the main learning
things about this game
is choosing who you're
going to try and help,
and these people do not convey
at all their characteristics,
which is why we're
redoing the art.
ANDREW GRANT: That makes sense.
RIK EBERHARDT:
And art is one way
of doing it, floating
dialog, floating
box is another way of doing
it, and floating boxes.
AUDIENCE: We have labels.
RIK EBERHARDT: Are they--
they're broken, or?
AUDIENCE: We deleted them,
because they-- they were just
hard to read, and
we didn't have them
moving with the characters,
so they would stay in place.
We could have made
them move, but we just
decided it was better
to redo the art than try
and make the little
captions better.
RIK EBERHARDT: No.
Oh, yeah.
That's--
AUDIENCE: If you guys don't
think I need to do the art,
let's not do the art.
PHILLIP TAN: Well, I
mean, the art is awesome,
but it is also a
huge bottleneck.
And if you fall
sick and then a lot
of the reliance
on your art to be
able to convey that important
information falls through,
and the project fails.
If you don't fall sick and
you get all your stuff done,
your game just looks
better, and it's awesome.
Right?
So.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So, I mean, we
have placeholders.
So if for some reason
I don't complete it,
we can just use
what we've got now.
PHILLIP TAN: But
I'm just thinking
about tinting the [INAUDIBLE],
or something that like--
like just through
software or something.
What else can you do that's a
little bit like as a backup?
AUDIENCE: So with
heat waves, one thing
that happens when you
get sick is you turn red.
So we could tint
them red over time,
and like have people starting
at different levels of red.
But I think-- and that's
actually something
that we might be
looking into separately.
Because something Pablo
talked to us about
was wanting to
convey that people
are getting sicker over time,
and that maybe once you see,
OK.
Somebody's turning red or
has an exclamation point,
or some way of conveying that.
Let's show the person
that they're sick.
The users need to know.
But that's something
we're doing as,
like, a secondary
thing, because we
want to focus primarily
on making the game better
as a whole right now.
RIK EBERHARDT: OK.
That's cool.
All right.
Yeah.
And all the things we're
saying are not at all, do this.
It's more--
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
No.
I--
RIK EBERHARDT: Think about this.
PHILLIP TAN: It's more we're
flagging our concerns rather
than telling you
how to solve it.
RIK EBERHARDT: And
prove us wrong, please.
AUDIENCE: All right.
I'll prove you guys wrong.
Don't worry.
PHILLIP TAN: All right.
Cool.
RIK EBERHARDT: The
other thing we had
was about tutorial
and ramping up, right?
PHILLIP TAN: Well, actually
more like ramping up.
So, right now, the
game's frantic.
Right?
It feels like you have to
be everywhere at all places.
And that's great
for somebody who
knows how to play
the game, and also
great for someone who's just
learning how to play the game.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PHILLIP TAN: So you already
have this concept of this.
I don't know if difficulty
is ramping up over this--
AUDIENCE: Actually, currently,
right now, it's not.
AUDIENCE: It's not.
We were planning on just
changing the number of people
that come up every day.
PHILLIP TAN: Yeah, so
maybe, I mean, just--
AUDIENCE: Starting
with less people.
PHILLIP TAN: Yeah, just
starting with less people,
or reducing the rate
in which people,
like, fall over or
something like that.
Just like, how do you ease
people into this situation?
AUDIENCE: That is kind of
set, because that depends
on temperature right now.
PHILLIP TAN: Right.
So that-- it's--
AUDIENCE: So we could just
have lower temperatures
in the first few days.
AUDIENCE: The first couple days.
We could definitely do that.
PHILLIP TAN: Yeah.
Just think about how you're
going to run people in.
That's definitely
better than going
to the expository tutorial
route, you know, of the I'm
just going to tell
you everything
that you need to know
and hope you remember it
when you play the game.
Ease people into the experience.
ANDREW GRANT: Yeah.
In fact, if it's
just the case that
you have your high risk person.
And if you've got
your-- really cool--
I'd like you to tell how
that might map to reality.
And you don't need to
tell me that they're
at risk if they're the ones
that keep dying like flies.
I'll be like, oh my gosh.
That's kind of a visceral
way learn that lesson.
Is the game-- when you
guys play the game,
do you feel that
you are winning it?
AUDIENCE: No. [LAUGH]
AUDIENCE: No.
ANDREW GRANT: All right.
So if you don't have it
really high in your backlog,
you probably should
put it there.
You need to do the gameplay
balancing first, first thing.
Because you need
to play test that.
Even if you guys are-- you can
use yourselves as play testers
to some extent for
difficulty, but keep in mind
that if you think the game is
hard, the game is impossible.
If you think the game is
easy, the game is hard.
AUDIENCE: Well, I think the
game's impossible right now.
ANDREW GRANT: All right.
AUDIENCE: Which has to
do-- I think we have, like,
a bug where too many people
show up, which I think
is something you noticed also.
It's just like, they're
all on fire all at once.
And I think we
definitely-- we only
intend to start with
like, four or five people,
and the fact that there's
like 20 there is an accident.
We're fixing that.
ANDREW GRANT: Sure.
And you could easily have
it-- they could arrive over
the course level, or whatever,
if that's what professors--
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Definitely.
ANDREW GRANT: But, yeah.
I would say make sure that that
game play piece is really high.
AUDIENCE: Definitely--
game balancing.
RIK EBERHARDT: Have you all
played Diner Dash at all?
Is it free online?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
RIK EBERHARDT: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I think I have.
Yeah.
PHILLIP TAN: Yeah.
You should be able to find
at least a video of it.
RIK EBERHARDT: Yeah.
ANDREW GRANT: Or Tapper.
PHILLIP TAN: Oh,
Root Beer Tapper.
RIK EBERHARDT: Diner
Dash or Tapper--
they're basically
time management games,
very similar to this one.
Take a look at those just to see
how they ramp up difficulty--
how easy it is when you
first start compared to after
about five minutes of play,
and try to think of that.
It might be as a baseline.
AUDIENCE: I had a question.
So, somewhere it says that
we should have explicit end
conditions for our game.
RIK EBERHARDT: That's an
explicit end condition.
You died.
PHILLIP TAN: Loss
is an end condition.
RIK EBERHARDT: Yeah.
PHILLIP TAN: You can--
AUDIENCE: Well, you don't
technically ever lose.
You just lose people.
RIK EBERHARDT: Oh.
So there should be some
point where I know that, OK.
I can stop trying right now.
I can try playing
the game again.
We try to keep it vague,
because every game
is going to do it differently.
If it's A, the heat
wave lasted four days,
and you ended those four days
of heat wave or whatever,
and that heat wave's
over, then you're done.
AUDIENCE: OK.
We were just going to do
it by, like, 20 people
dead or something like that.
RIK EBERHARDT: Yeah.
ANDREW GRANT: That
will work fine.
RIK EBERHARDT: That's fine, too.
Whatever is best
for the project.
PHILLIP TAN: You can
actually do both, right?
If you keep this town going
20 days without losing
x number of people, you
win, otherwise you lose.
ANDREW GRANT: That's an
aesthetic choice, I think.
The modern game shtick is that
all games have a win condition.
But classic games didn't.
They had a lose condition only.
PHILLIP TAN: Yeah.
You could be like a
Tetris kind of thing,
where you just-- how
long can you last?
But summer doesn't last forever.
If somebody goes for,
like, you know, 200 days,
it's probably not a
heat wave any more.
ANDREW GRANT: That's funny.
That's funny.
After 90 days, you're
like, summer is over.
No one is dying of heat wave.
Wait for the sequel-- Winter.
[LAUGHTER]
ANDREW GRANT: Cold Snap.
AUDIENCE: Maybe it's only
winter all year long.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
ANDREW GRANT: That's true.
Some parts of the world actually
is heat wave all year around.
PHILLIP TAN: Mhm.
Singapore.
[LAUGH]
RIK EBERHARDT: Cool.
Any other stuff?
PHILLIP TAN: No, that's it.
RIK EBERHARDT: Last thing for
me, then, is product backlog
item 20-- menu user interface.
Outside menu.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
RIK EBERHARDT: What is that?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So that's not actually
well explained.
That has to do with the
insoluble items, which--
Roy isn't here.
But Roy is working on it.
AUDIENCE: It's kind of like
the pods are like add water
stations, add umbrella.
RIK EBERHARDT: All right.
Cool.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
RIK EBERHARDT: We
just weren't sure
what you were
talking about there.
But that's enough.
AUDIENCE: I meant to fix that.
I forgot.
RIK EBERHARDT: No.
These documents are for you.
As long as you understand
what's going on-- that's
why Phillip was saying, yes.
We didn't understand.
There's probably some things in
your head that you understand.
But also, in case
you didn't see that,
then we wanted to go over that.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PHILLIP TAN: Yep.
RIK EBERHARDT: All right.
ANDREW GRANT: And
another thing--
so add water-- is
it red on there
because it's high priority?
AUDIENCE: No.
Red means it was cut.
ANDREW GRANT: Ah.
Awesome.
OK, cool.
RIK EBERHARDT: And we like
that-- cutting the features
and leaving them there is fine.
Sometimes, as a morale,
removing them is also good.
Have a party when you do that.
ANDREW GRANT: Well, trying to--
RIK EBERHARDT: But
as memory, they're
good for institutional
memory, to know, hey.
We thought about this.
We cut it.
Later on, oh-- assuming you
had another couple weeks.
We can go back to it.
ANDREW GRANT: Actually,
almost every project
I work on, I now have
a do not do list.
Like, not a to do list.
Like this is the
thing I thought about,
and I really want to do it.
And I'm going to
write down here so I
know I'm going to ever do it.
So later, when I think
about, what about that?
Oh, right.
PHILLIP TAN: You're
not going to do it.
AUDIENCE: Never do that.
ANDREW GRANT: Never do that.
Because I don't have time.
And so I think even
if you don't keep
those on your main
to-do list, it's
cool to have them
there for a little bit,
just so you
remember-- oh, right.
We cut that.
AUDIENCE: Mhm.
RIK EBERHARDT: OK.
PHILLIP TAN: Well, thank you.
RIK EBERHARDT: Thanks.
And actually, so
the vision statement
isn't due until December 10.
AUDIENCE: OK.
RIK EBERHARDT: Is just we
wanted to give you the chance
to make an update
now if you could,
but this discussion
is fulfilling that.
So, that's good.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
Thank you, sir.
RIK EBERHARDT: All right?
Thanks.
Have a great holiday.
All right, Drew.
When you're ready, go ahead
and play another game.
ANDREW GRANT: Yes.
Oh, excellent.
AUDIENCE: There's
still some instructions
which are missing
from within the game.
ANDREW GRANT: OK.
AUDIENCE: So I'll just
explain those now.
So the goal of the game is to
build up your victory progress
to 100%.
And the way you do that is by
setting your toys to build or--
ANDREW GRANT: Or gather.
Mhm.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
And you do that by clicking.
So the story is like you
brought your toys to the beach,
and they have
these sand castles.
But then the waves-- like, if
they cover the sand castles,
the toys will then take damage.
And they can only get
hit by the waves twice.
They take damage if they start
underwater or end underwater.
And so in order to
prevent your toys
from getting swept
under the waves,
you can move them by clicking
and dragging them to castles.
ANDREW GRANT: OK.
AUDIENCE: And then they will
move one castle at a time.
So this one will
move here, here.
ANDREW GRANT: OK.
It's pretty much the same as
[INAUDIBLE] play test, then,
the last I saw.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
ANDREW GRANT: OK.
AUDIENCE: And then
the last thing-- so
you can hover over
this to see what
the predictions are, and you
can hover over the castles.
ANDREW GRANT: Oh, I see.
And they're no longer perfect.
Excellent.
I like that.
I like that change.
All right.
Cool.
I'm going to say, again, this
toy is immune to water damage.
AUDIENCE: But he does
not need to be put away.
ANDREW GRANT: Ah, OK.
OK.
RIK EBERHARDT: So
while he's playing,
did you update
your-- did you have
a discussion about
cutting features
after Monday, as a team?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
RIK EBERHARDT: Did
you cut anything?
AUDIENCE: We cut, like, kind
of any sort of big changes
where we would give
people special abilities,
or give any sort of long
tutorial kind of like that.
RIK EBERHARDT: OK.
So you cut things you hadn't
started yet, basically.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
RIK EBERHARDT: OK.
Anything that if you
had to cut today, like
could you cut
anything right now,
or does everything have
to go in the way you've
thought about the game?
AUDIENCE: So what we mainly
have left is UI changes--
like make this a cloud it fits
into the theme of our game,
or add arrows to show where--
ANDREW GRANT: Where
they're going to go,
and how they're going.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
ANDREW GRANT: OK.
AUDIENCE: And so a lot of
that is necessary to make sure
that our game is standalone.
But I guess the
worst case scenario,
we make that a blob of
text, which would be, like,
absolute worst-case scenario.
RIK EBERHARDT: Do you
already have the feature
to do a blob of text?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
That would be our--
RIK EBERHARDT: It's
already in there, or?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
That would be our menu screen,
which we didn't show you, but.
RIK EBERHARDT: OK.
Cool.
OK.
For your vision
statement-- so I said
if you have a new one
today, we'd like to see it.
If you don't have
a new one today,
make sure you update your
vision statement before you turn
in the game on December 10.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Yeah.
We do have an updated
vision statement now.
RIK EBERHARDT: Oh, you do?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
RIK EBERHARDT: Cool.
Cool.
Then I'll review it.
So we review--
AUDIENCE: Should I submit
it to Stellar though?
RIK EBERHARDT: Yeah.
Submit it to Stellar.
Submit it under the
December 10 one.
And then on December 10,
if anything else changes,
resubmit it on the
December 10 one.
That's the one we're going
to use and judge the game by.
The main thing I saw
on the one you have now
is that just the 30
seconds of gameplay
is really, really vague.
So if you changed that for this
new one, then you did good.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
OK.
Yeah.
We made it a lot
more concrete, now
that we have a more concrete--
RIK EBERHARDT: Great.
Cool.
That's exactly right.
So the biggest thing
that Phillip and I saw
was about your-- basically
about the representational art,
the quality spent on
the representational art
compared to other feedback.
PHILLIP TAN: Yeah.
So right now, the graphics
that you have in the game
look really cute, and
they're attractive.
They're endearing.
They make people want to
people want to play the game.
And then your UI isn't
up to that, right?
You have this issue-- and this
happens in a lot of games--
where the quality of one
asset or one kind of asset
is showing how far back the
rest of your assets are.
And this obviously
means that you
might be inclined to make sure
that the rest of the stuff
looks as good as what
you've got-- things
like the background,
for instance--
probably the most important
part of the entire game
is the background.
But it also looks like
the least visually thing
that you've got on screen.
AUDIENCE: That's true.
PHILLIP TAN: And
also things like
when you want to instruct your
characters to move around,
for instance.
Like you said, right now
you have to explain it.
But I expect to see some sort
of visual feedback, UI feedback,
when I have, say, instructed
someone to move somewhere else.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
That's what we're
planning to do.
We'll probably have
the go to destination
and the character goes--
PHILLIP TAN: And
the danger right now
is that your characters and
your sandcastles and your clouds
have set the standard
of visual quality
that the rest of
your stuff now needs
to meet, which is a
pretty tall-- I mean,
you clearly have
the skills to do it.
The question is whether
you have the time to do it.
And that's what
I'm worried about.
AUDIENCE: Sure.
PHILLIP TAN: Because you
don't just want people--
you want people to look
at your characterize
when they're trying to
think about whether they
want to play a game.
When they're playing
your game, you
want them looking at that
background, and where they're
going, and the quality--
RIK EBERHARDT: So when it
comes to a feature like-- OK,
here's an arrow going
from one place to another.
Do you already
have code in place
to do that, but just you
don't have the art asset?
Do you have the art
asset, but not the code?
Or do you not have any of it?
AUDIENCE: I think that
was like our, actually,
highest priority to
implement highlight
to implement by, like, the
end of Thanksgiving weekend.
So that would be,
like, our number one--
RIK EBERHARDT: But you're
starting from 0 and going--
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
RIK EBERHARDT: OK.
Cool.
AUDIENCE: Don't they have
arrows showing where--
RIK EBERHARDT: They have arrows
showing that they are moving,
but not where they're moving to.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
ANDREW GRANT: And do you have
to click twice on a character?
Is that correct?
AUDIENCE: No.
ANDREW GRANT: No?
OK.
It's just a click and hold?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
ANDREW GRANT: Yeah.
But-- yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, it's
a little difficult.
ANDREW GRANT: The
cancel is-- I mean,
the cancel is intuitive
to a computer programmer,
but no one else.
Is there sound?
AUDIENCE: Uh, no sound.
AUDIENCE: That's another
one to be implemented.
RIK EBERHARDT: OK.
And how far are you on sound?
Is it a--
AUDIENCE: We have
potential background music,
but we're trying to figure
out which one we actually
want to put in.
RIK EBERHARDT: Well, what about
sound for I clicked a thing,
and sound for--
AUDIENCE: I have
worked on the sound,
but we haven't put it in yet.
RIK EBERHARDT: OK.
That's--
ANDREW GRANT: My
recommendation on that
stuff is don't worry about
picking the right background
music.
RIK EBERHARDT: Yeah.
ANDREW GRANT: Put in
stupid background music,
and then you will
hear it, and then
you'll be motivated
to change it.
But most importantly,
you'll have
proven that your code can
support background music
and click simultaneously,
et cetera, et cetera-- which
it can, because it's not hard.
But just be safe.
Put in placeholder sounds,
put in placeholder art
for whatever.
If it is, in fact,
the case that you
end up with your cool, cute
toys being more visually
exciting than your UI, there's
another cheat you can do,
which is lower the
quality of your characters
if you don't have time to
improve the quality of your UI.
PHILLIP TAN: Just pixelize them.
ANDREW GRANT: [LAUGH]
Obviously, improving the quality
of your UI is better.
But again, you can
cope with that.
But, yeah.
You do want people to
focus on the right things.
RIK EBERHARDT: From a
usability standpoint,
we're going to be looking
stronger at if I click a thing,
it gives me an audio
feedback that I
clicked a thing,
more than there's
background music going on.
ANDREW GRANT: Sure.
RIK EBERHARDT: Background
music's an aesthetic element
that we're also
going to look at,
but when we're ranking
our priorities,
usability is higher
than aesthetic.
ANDREW GRANT: Yeah.
Another thing is
that, right now,
for usability, there is no hint.
So we're talking about hints
about where is this going?
The guy is moving,
not moving, whatever.
But currently, there's no
clue that he's clickable,
except for the instructions.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
ANDREW GRANT: So you want
him to react in some way.
The easy, easy way is
to make them bigger,
and just scale them.
So have them scale up, or
something, when your mouse is
over them, or something.
Just give us some
really simple clue.
It doesn't have to be
complicated code-wise,
but you definitely
need that clue.
Also, the part where
this guy, if he's-- this
castle's perfectly safe.
It's never in danger.
I saw in your backlog
we've got to figure out
how to solve that problem.
I would make that pretty
high priority-- actually,
higher priority than any
polishing you're doing.
Because your game, currently,
has a pretty easy strategy
of leave a guy there and
click for 100 turns, right?
AUDIENCE: Well,
the only thing is
you have to be at [INAUDIBLE].
ANDREW GRANT: Sure.
You may never win, but it's
easy to never lose, certainly.
That's not interesting.
Actually, no-- this
guy, by himself,
doing nothing but building,
can win the game in 100 turns.
Right?
So--
AUDIENCE: Our proposed
solution to that
is after you lose two guys or
one guy, you lose the game.
RIK EBERHARDT: OK.
Cool.
AUDIENCE: That's
not [INAUDIBLE].
RIK EBERHARDT: Sure.
All right.
Cool.
But I would try to
make that sooner,
because your game is not-- make
sure anything that your game
has not done-- like, I
feel like that is not
done with that flaw.
And, as you actually
mentioned in your backlog,
this may add new tasks
and bugs, because it will.
So make sure that's
relatively high priority.
AUDIENCE: OK.
ANDREW GRANT: I would say--
PHILLIP TAN: Because
then you have
to test all of that on people.
ANDREW GRANT: Yeah.
PHILLIP TAN: Because
you are going to have
a different kind of bar graph.
That's what I'm getting
from what you're describing.
You're going to maybe
rearrange the way
how your fonts and your progress
bars and stuff, and all of that
is going to be understood
differently by people who've
never seen your game.
And you need to get that
information pretty soon.
ANDREW GRANT: Oddly,
in some sense,
the poor bar graph tells
me is that, right now, I
know this is a bar graph.
It's probably giving
me information.
So I should figure out
what that information is.
As soon as you turn
this into something
that looks like a
cloud or something,
I might stop knowing
that it's information.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
That's interesting.
ANDREW GRANT: Right.
So right now, I see it
and I think to myself,
what does it do?
RIK EBERHARDT: That's something
you can really quickly paper
prototype and get in front
of people who have never
seen this before.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
ANDREW GRANT: Yeah.
In fact, you could take
a screenshot of this.
And just stick it
into Photoshop.
Put your thing on there.
PHILLIP TAN: Mock it up.
ANDREW GRANT: What
does this mean,
random person on the street
I've never met before?
[LAUGH]
PHILLIP TAN: Family
member that you might see.
ANDREW GRANT: Over
Thanksgiving, for example.
But, yeah.
You don't need to put it
in the game to test it, so.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PHILLIP TAN: Yeah.
There's a lot of different
ways you can get that bar graph
to look like it's part of
the scene while making it
look like a bar graph.
It doesn't necessarily need
to be made out of clouds.
It could be in a cloud.
ANDREW GRANT: Yeah.
PHILLIP TAN: It could
be projected on a cloud.
It could be--
ANDREW GRANT: Yeah.
RIK EBERHARDT: Yeah.
OK.
ANDREW GRANT: All right.
RIK EBERHARDT: Moving on.
First things first.
On Monday, I mentioned try to
do an updated vision statement.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
RIK EBERHARDT: It's
due December 10.
If you have one now and it's
in Stellar now, awesome.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
We did not submit it.
RIK EBERHARDT: OK.
AUDIENCE: We haven't submitted
it, but we did just rewrite it.
RIK EBERHARDT: OK.
Cool.
Then submit that to Stellar
under the December 10
final one.
AUDIENCE: Final-- OK.
RIK EBERHARDT: And then
resubmit it again with changes.
AUDIENCE: Resubmit
it again for changes?
Sure.
RIK EBERHARDT: OK?
The big thing we see--
AUDIENCE: What do you
want risks to have?
Because it seems
like by the end,
their risks are
kind of meaningless.
ANDREW GRANT: By December
10, risks are too late.
RIK EBERHARDT: Yeah.
So just keep the risks
you originally had.
AUDIENCE: OK.
RIK EBERHARDT: If
you want to have
AUDIENCE: So we updated
the risks right now,
because pretty much ever risk
we had before didn't make sense.
RIK EBERHARDT: That's perfect.
The thing I'm really looking
at is 30 seconds of game play.
AUDIENCE: That
completely changed.
RIK EBERHARDT: That's cool.
Because that's the thing
we're judging your game one.
If your game does not look
like the 30-second game play,
it's a huge red flag for us.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PHILLIP TAN: Actually,
there probably
are still risks on December 10.
There won't be
implementation risks.
It won't be like, can
we implement something?
It will be more of the what
happens when real people try
to use this thing?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PHILLIP TAN: Right?
So you can write those up.
AUDIENCE: Well, I think
that risk is December 8.
PHILLIP TAN: Possibly.
AUDIENCE: So--
PHILLIP TAN: Well, I mean--
AUDIENCE: Because we're
testing with 100 players.
PHILLIP TAN: Yeah.
But what happens when the
next 100 players come along?
AUDIENCE: Sure, sure.
PHILLIP TAN: What
happens long-term?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
There's real-- there's
real deployment.
PHILLIP TAN: You
can change it then.
AUDIENCE: Charlie.
RIK EBERHARDT: For your
product backlog and task list,
are these prioritized
when you look at them?
Like, you're using Asana, right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
RIK EBERHARDT: Do
you use priority?
AUDIENCE: We did not
do a good job of--
AUDIENCE: We sort of
do soft priority--
small, medium,
large-- on some tasks.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
We have different--
RIK EBERHARDT: No.
That size.
PHILLIP TAN: No--
ANDREW GRANT: That size.
But you don't necessarily have--
AUDIENCE: So I
think theoretically,
they should be
ordered by priority.
RIK EBERHARDT: OK.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
That would be--
RIK EBERHARDT: OK.
Because it doesn't
look like they're
ordered by name
and something else.
I don't know.
We couldn't tell how
you were authorizing it,
so hopefully you are
thinking about that
as you are moving
towards the deadline.
You're going to have to choose--
I'm going to work on this right
now.
Make sure it's organized.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I think now that will
be more important.
RIK EBERHARDT: How are
you-- are you doing work
over the weekend,
over the break?
AUDIENCE: I will.
AUDIENCE: I probably will do
a little bit, but mostly other
work.
RIK EBERHARDT: Oh.
No.
We tell you don't.
Like, don't plan on
having, like-- that's
bonus work, right?
But if you are working
individually elsewhere
and you're not able
to talk to each other,
how do you know what
you're working on?
That's the big thing for that.
PHILLIP TAN: One
of the big things
that we're noticing on your
list of things-- a lot of them
are both the server
and game-system based.
Probably also because you've
been getting a lot of feedback
from Pablo and people how have
been running this game in front
of the audience, we're not
getting a whole lot of feedback
from the people who are actually
playing it on the playing site.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
That's true.
PHILLIP TAN: So the thing that
I'm really, really worried
about is that the
client-side user
interface doesn't look like it's
actually changed all that much.
I'm sure the technology has,
but the actual user experience
hasn't.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PHILLIP TAN: So I am worried
that you're not actually
getting in useful
usability information
and that iterative
playing experience.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
RIK EBERHARDT: And so you
mentioned in the presentation
you were dropping Phaser.
are you in the process of
dropping Phaser, or started?
AUDIENCE: We are
done with with that.
RIK EBERHARDT: You're
done with that.
So you're no longer in Phaser.
You've got something else?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
RIK EBERHARDT: It's buggy,
but you've got something else.
AUDIENCE: It's a
little bit buggy,
but it's almost as
good as we had before.
RIK EBERHARDT: OK.
Cool.
Because we were going to ask do
you really need to drop Phaser?
And so you're already
done, so why bother asking?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
RIK EBERHARDT: What else?
Oh.
And give some time looking
at your scoring mechanism.
While you kind of
hand-waved through it
during the presentation--
as we've got,
here's a couple of different
ways we can do scoring.
Are you thinking about
scoring as a team?
Or are you relying on the
client to come up with that?
AUDIENCE: So I'm
actually not sure why
our scoring works
the way it does,
because it's harder
to implement--
RIK EBERHARDT: Yeah.
It's also not very intuitive.
AUDIENCE: It doesn't make sense.
RIK EBERHARDT: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Like, there's
a specific function
that makes sure that you only
get one point when you might as
well get more than one point.
I think that's just something
that has been low-priority,
and hasn't been
fixed-- especially
because nobody
actually understands
how their getting points.
And they only ask at the end
of the game, wait a minute.
How did I get points?
RIK EBERHARDT: Yeah.
PHILLIP TAN: Two
ways that you can
resolve that-- one
is you play test it,
and then you ask people
how they think that they
should be getting points.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PHILLIP TAN: And the other
way is you just ask Paolo.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PHILLIP TAN: And let him
make a decision for you.
RIK EBERHARDT: The third way--
if you're with family members,
you can play the
regular, the analog game.
Come up with a scoring
mechanism-- like, just do it.
You don't need to be
programming to do it.
You can probably do
it really quickly.
PHILLIP TAN: My guess is that a
accumulated scoring system will
give you more differentiation
between players,
whereas the one point for
everybody kind of situation
means a lot of people
get the same score.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
ANDREW GRANT: Are these-- it
looks like you have, actually,
three backlogs.
Is that true?
RIK EBERHARDT: This is backlog,
and these are tasks lists.
ANDREW GRANT: Oh, I see.
I see.
RIK EBERHARDT: That's on the--
ANDREW GRANT: I see.
RIK EBERHARDT:
Same system, yeah.
ANDREW GRANT: Oh, OK.
So does that mean it's repeated?
This is the backlog and
these are task lists,
are the same thing?
I think they're
repeated in both places.
Do you have one list--
AUDIENCE: No.
RIK EBERHARDT: Yeah.
ANDREW GRANT: So you
have somewhere one list
that lists everything you
need to do, prioritized.
So that way, one of you--
AUDIENCE: OK.
We don't have something
exactly like that.
ANDREW GRANT: And the
reason why you want that
is so that if I'm
working on the back end
and I have gotten all of
my priority two stuff done.
I'm working the
priority three stuff.
But on the front end,
there's a whole bunch
of priority one bugs.
I need to switch
to the front end.
AUDIENCE: I see.
ANDREW GRANT: Right?
AUDIENCE: So far I
don't think anybody
has-- initial on the switch.
It was permanently switched.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
ANDREW GRANT: Now, part of
that, there's a learning curve
problem for doing that.
But if you get that
far out of whack,
you really need to be ready,
or to be aware of the fact
that that might happen.
AUDIENCE: I see.
Yeah.
ANDREW GRANT: So
it also does you
no good job to implement a
feature on the back end that's
not implemented
on the front end,
and vice versa, really-- for the
features that pair, at least,
right?
So there's got to be
really close communication.
And one way to handle that
is to have a unified list--
bugs and features
intermingled sometimes.
AUDIENCE: Right.
ANDREW GRANT: What's the most
important thing to do next?
But I would be a
little bit worried
if this is your
entire organization
system, about stuff
falling through the cracks
pretty easily, especially since
you're dividing your team up
into subgroups to sort of handle
front end, back end problems.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
ANDREW GRANT: That
means that there's
a-- it's not a
communication barrier,
but there's no highway
of communication.
Since you are
separated out, you will
tend to forget to inform the
other side of what's going on.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
ANDREW GRANT: So, and the one
list also helps with that.
And also, let's see.
Did I see here that you're
already adding word lists
or did I make that up?
No, I just saw cloud,
words, and export.
RIK EBERHARDT: They have a
word cloud on the back end now.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Not for players--
ANDREW GRANT: I see.
AUDIENCE: --for the back end.
That's been around.
ANDREW GRANT: Got it.
So the back end-- I see.
I see.
OK.
So are you, for
example, not bothering
to have a feature for
collusion or cheating?
AUDIENCE: No.
ANDREW GRANT: OK.
RIK EBERHARDT: Yeah.
Cool.
AUDIENCE: I think we have
no anti-cheating tasks.
ANDREW GRANT: All right.
Cool.
You probably should mention
that explicitly somewhere.
I'm not sure where
that goes, though.
PHILLIP TAN: Maybe
interpretation document.
ANDREW GRANT: Yeah.
It's an anti-task, certainly.
AUDIENCE: That's actually--
ANDREW GRANT: And to
the client, for example,
you'd want to make sure
the client knows this
is the thing we're not doing.
And you probably don't care,
because of your use case.
But we should mention
in case you go, no.
Wait a minute.
RIK EBERHARDT: Your
final presentation's
a great place for that,
as a here's something
we thought about and
didn't do because of that.
ANDREW GRANT: Yeah.
RIK EBERHARDT: Yeah.
ANDREW GRANT: Although if
you do have any conversation
with the client, mention that.
Because if they're
like, that's crazy,
you want to know that before
the final presentation--
you might not be able to do
anything about it with the time
you've got, but it'd be good
to be aware if maybe there is
an easy solution the client come
up with or whatever that you
haven't-- because maybe full
cheating stopping is not
necessary, but some
minor things are.
AUDIENCE: I mean,
I think the way
they run it-- if you cheated it
would be obvious, first of all.
Like, they're going
to show you did it.
ANDREW GRANT: Oh,
because the cloud.
AUDIENCE: So, like--
ANDREW GRANT: OK, yeah.
AUDIENCE: What you did--
ANDREW GRANT: Who put
cat and dog in here?
That's ridiculous.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
ANDREW GRANT: OK.
Sure.
All right.
Cool.
That may well be
enough right there.
AUDIENCE: And
also, they wants us
to focus on pretty
serious players, right?
ANDREW GRANT: So who aren't
going to be cheating?
AUDIENCE: They're
not going to cheat.
ANDREW GRANT: All right.
Cool.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
ANDREW GRANT: That's
a nice advantage.
And that's a thing
to include in your--
if you mention your target
audience is, in fact, people
who've already
drunk the Kool-Aid.
They're already on your team.
They're not trying to--
it's not whack people
on the internet who are going
to do whatever they want.
That's an important--
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
It's almost like not players.
ANDREW GRANT: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: It's not
a typical player.
ANDREW GRANT: That's
an important thing
to mention in your
vision statement,
actually, if it's not
in there already--
I'm behind on that, but.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PHILLIP TAN: One
other thing is given
that your game is
designed to work
both on phone and
on laptop, on PC,
you do want to set up
multiple test sessions
so that you can test your user
interface on both clients.
Maybe you're testing
them simultaneously,
but then you have to make
sure that when you're getting
your usability feedback, you
are getting some usability
feedback on the phone
users, and some--
because it's very different
on the different device.
AUDIENCE: So I think that's
sort of a weird feature where,
as far as the
class is concerned,
I don't think we care
about the mobile interface.
RIK EBERHARDT: OK.
All right.
AUDIENCE: Like,
that's not something
that we're promising
in terms of the course.
RIK EBERHARDT: OK.
Oh, good.
Good.
PHILLIP TAN: That wasn't clear
on the priority list, too.
AUDIENCE: On the other
hand, it seems easy enough,
and the client really wants it.
RIK EBERHARDT: OK.
PHILLIP TAN: You
might want to do
we'll guarantee that
the PC site will work,
and if you wanted us to do
the mobile site, maybe pay us.
RIK EBERHARDT: Here's 0.9B.
You get 1.0 with the dot.
PHILLIP TAN: I mean,
seriously, this
is real work that you're
doing that real people get
paid to do.
And for the sake
of this class, we
want you to turn in
a polished product,
and we never ask you to
target two platforms.
The client does, obviously.
But then it's also reasonable
to tell the client,
first priority is get one--
RIK EBERHARDT: Beyond
the scope of the class.
AUDIENCE: Well, I think he's--
he's been very good about
mentioning that every time,
that he wants us to do well
in the class, not
make him happy.
ANDREW GRANT: Sure.
Sure.
Well, and that's another place
where your prioritization can
help a lot, right?
You want to make
sure that the web
interface on a thing
with a keyboard
is the one that's
the highest priority.
And if you have time, then
you make the mobile one work.
And you're already going
to have problems for you
poor mobile people
on their phones, who
are typing really
slowly compared
to the people on
their computers.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
This is something
we talked about,
in fairness, that
sort of got dropped
because it's very hard to do.
RIK EBERHARDT: Oh, yeah.
You can't compensate
for the fairness,
but it's a thing to be
aware of, obviously.
All right.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So I have one question
about deployment.
How long after the course
will the game have to be up?
RIK EBERHARDT: At
least through January.
PHILLIP TAN: Or through
the whole of January.
RIK EBERHARDT: Yeah.
Through the whole of
January, if possible.
And if you can't do
that, let us know.
And we'll come up with
a different solution.
Grading is really soon.
We're going to do grading.
Yeah.
ANDREW GRANT: Grading will be
before then-- way before then,
obviously.
RIK EBERHARDT: If you
have a way to deploy it
to a different platform,
a different server,
if that is what is necessary,
then we'll think about that.
But that's the other thing.
We're going to have a
conversation with Pablo
at the end of the
class to figure out
how it's going to be used.
PHILLIP TAN: And OCW would
like to figure out, also.
RIK EBERHARDT: Yeah.
OCW wants to actually--
that's right.
Forever.
ANDREW GRANT: [LAUGH]
AUDIENCE: So ours is a
little bit more tricky.
RIK EBERHARDT: Yours
is more tricky.
PHILLIP TAN: I'll find
a solution for that.
RIK EBERHARDT: Something we
could talk about after class,
because I don't think we can
talk about it during class.
That after January 1, it's not
going to be part of the grade.
Because the grade's already
done by December 15.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
RIK EBERHARDT: But
for OCW capture,
we'd like to have
something there.
ANDREW GRANT: What
does it run on now?
AUDIENCE: It's a node server.
ANDREW GRANT: It's
a node server.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Actually, it's two
node servers, unfortunately.
One for the back end and
then one that runs the front.
AUDIENCE: The front end
is just static files.
AUDIENCE: Actually, the
front end is HTML now.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
RIK EBERHARDT: So
maybe we can talk
to [INAUDIBLE] about finding
money to pay for the servers,
basically.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PHILLIP TAN: And maybe
even money for one of your
[INAUDIBLE].
ANDREW GRANT: Exactly.
RIK EBERHARDT: So
that's something
to put in your vision
statement too-- or as a release
note or something, somewhere.
ANDREW GRANT: Is there any place
the caveats go for the risks--
AUDIENCE: The risks
section might be OK.
ANDREW GRANT: Yeah, actually
risks is a good place.
That's as close as
we've got for that.
Risks, cheating, risks,
server goes down.
[LAUGH]
RIK EBERHARDT: All right.
We've taken too
much of your time.
Thank you.
Have a good holiday.
ANDREW GRANT: Thank
you very much.
RIK EBERHARDT: So
looking at your project,
the biggest thing we
found was can you cut
one of your main characters?
Is that even possible?
AUDIENCE: So, yeah.
We already cut one of our games.
And we're at three.
RIK EBERHARDT: So
how-- you're at three?
So you cut one down to three.
Do you need three?
Is three the magic number
that just says, everything's
wrapped up together?
Or if one of those fell
away and we polished two,
is that good enough?
AUDIENCE: I think two would
significantly change how
the game fundamentals.
It's kind of a puzzle.
So it's like if you only had two
clues, which is three clues, so
more of a puzzle element.
AUDIENCE: Also the fact
that each game covers--
we cut down one
game and combined
it to minimize-- to still
try to cover everything
we want to teach.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
We'd have to find
to teach the-- what
was in the game we cut in
other game dialog or something.
ANDREW GRANT: Absolutely.
Cool.
RIK EBERHARDT: So
cutting them in the game
would, in fact,
mean a lot of work.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
ANDREW GRANT: Great.
That's the perfect,
excellent answer.
RIK EBERHARDT: Otherwise, we're
looking through your product
backlog.
Your prioritization looked
really good to me and Phillip.
AUDIENCE: Great.
RIK EBERHARDT: So I think
you're-- do you feel like
you're in control of the
information that you have right
now, of where you
are on your team,
where you are on your project?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I think our team, since
the way we structured it,
it's like everything
has to come together.
But putting it
together will not take
as long as it would originally.
Because we kind of
all divided up tasks.
Everyone's working on
the same kind of tasks,
like for the same
thing, but we just
have to put it all together,
if that makes sense.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So it's very modular, since
we have three mini games.
Then we have somebody to
work on the main scene.
And then we have end scenes.
So you just have to put
some pieces together.
RIK EBERHARDT: OK.
Cool.
Can you pull up the vision
statement really quick?
ANDREW GRANT: Yeah.
RIK EBERHARDT: So on
Monday I mentioned talk
about vision statement.
Change it if you need to.
On yours, it looked pretty good.
I really like the
narrative aspect
of the 30 seconds of game play.
Does your game still feel like
there's a narrative to it,
though?
Like, is it as
strong in that game?
AUDIENCE: So I think it's
probably not as strong
as we want it to
be now but, that's
only because the
dialog hasn't been--
AUDIENCE: --really written.
I mean, been drafted.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Exactly.
We're going to that [INAUDIBLE].
RIK EBERHARDT: OK.
Cool.
It's not due until
December 10, for reals.
So that was an exercise just
to make sure that you do it now
rather than waiting
until the last minute.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
RIK EBERHARDT: So once you
have a finished version in,
turn it in on Stellar under
the December 10 deadline.
And, yeah.
Really make sure that the
30 seconds of game play
are more representative of
what the game really is.
AUDIENCE: OK.
RIK EBERHARDT: Are you having
problems with the title?
AUDIENCE: Hmm?
RIK EBERHARDT: Are you having
problems with the title?
AUDIENCE: I would say so.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
RIK EBERHARDT: Is the problem
too many ideas, or too few?
AUDIENCE: Too few.
RIK EBERHARDT: OK.
That's actually the easier
one to deal with, I think.
Because when you resolve
it, no one's mad.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
RIK EBERHARDT: What are
your strategies for that?
AUDIENCE: We haven't--
we've been ignoring it.
ANDREW GRANT: You've
been ignoring it.
AUDIENCE: OK.
That's-- that's actually
a fine place to be.
Because it's relatively
to brainstorm it.
But if you tried that
and it didn't work, eh.
ANDREW GRANT: Because, yeah.
A title does-- even if it
happens last minute-- it's
another art asset to create.
Another thing to integrate.
RIK EBERHARDT: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
We've been thinking
like, as we do it,
we'll just get a
name for the village,
and we'll be like,
Saving Village Name.
RIK EBERHARDT: Village name?
ANDREW GRANT: Beautiful.
RIK EBERHARDT: Sure.
That sounds easy.
That's fine.
Have you been brainstorming
water themes, like water names?
AUDIENCE: Water names?
RIK EBERHARDT: Maybe like
the Ghanaian word for water?
AUDIENCE: We looked
through like Ghana stuff,
like Ghana city names.
And then we haven't
actually, like,
looked through specifically--
we have to work on that.
ANDREW GRANT: OK.
RIK EBERHARDT: All right.
Is that on your backlog?
AUDIENCE: It is.
RIK EBERHARDT: All right.
Score.
AUDIENCE: It's at the--
ANDREW GRANT: The
very, very bottom.
Yeah, yeah.
RIK EBERHARDT: All right.
Cool.
AUDIENCE: Find a name
that isn't offensive.
ANDREW GRANT: [LAUGH] Yeah.
That's important.
RIK EBERHARDT: How has that
been going along since we last
talked to you, about the--
AUDIENCE: Research?
RIK EBERHARDT:
Research and stuff?
Are you done with
that, or are you
still on-progress with that?
AUDIENCE: Well, we got together
and did a mega research,
like-- find all of the things
and get inspiration from it,
mainly for the
artists, so that we can
get a cohesive theme together.
And I think that
also helps inform
the decision, the design behind
water filtration, for example.
So, yeah.
I mean, I think still
if the artists ever
need to make something
new, we still
look up and see if we
can find references.
RIK EBERHARDT: Yeah.
OK.
That's good.
AUDIENCE: But--
RIK EBERHARDT: All right.
ANDREW GRANT: So I
don't think that I
have played this game,
because mini game sounds
like a new thing to me.
Saving All the Village.
Give me a quick
five-second play-through.
I hit that, I'm sure.
Mini Game 1.
Yes.
Purified water
conversation goes here.
I will purify.
Yay!
This is the mini game?
Hmm.
AUDIENCE: The down button
should be a Next button.
ANDREW GRANT: Oh, excellent.
Oh, excellent.
And now I play the game where
I'm doing essential sorting,
and this is an actual game.
All right, cool.
I am going to assume that
I do something like this.
All right, cool.
The main thing I-- so when I am
putting on my feasibility hat
and I hear the word mini
game, I always think [GASP].
But it seems like you
actually have a mini game.
Good job-- a mini game.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGH]
RIK EBERHARDT: Mini
games tend to just be--
AUDIENCE: Game games?
RIK EBERHARDT: --many games.
AUDIENCE: Many games. [LAUGH]
RIK EBERHARDT: M-A-N-Y.
ANDREW GRANT: Yes.
Many games is not what you want.
What you actually
want is mini game.
RIK EBERHARDT: [LAUGH]
ANDREW GRANT: Oh my gosh.
RIK EBERHARDT: This is
[INAUDIBLE]. [LAUGH]
ANDREW GRANT: All right.
You've got a lot of-- you've
got a lot of features, here.
RIK EBERHARDT: Yeah.
ANDREW GRANT: And that is cool.
RIK EBERHARDT: Is this a
mini game, or is this--
AUDIENCE: This is the mini game.
RIK EBERHARDT: All right.
ANDREW GRANT: All right.
All right.
I see here.
OK.
Cool.
And so how much
more do you think
is going into these mini games?
AUDIENCE: So we just--
for two of them,
I haven't actually had an
update on the symptoms one.
RIK EBERHARDT: On
the second one.
AUDIENCE: But the symptoms
one should probably just
be dialog and the pictures.
That's it.
ANDREW GRANT: Got it.
AUDIENCE: The water
filtration should
be instruction page, or
interactive tutorial beginning,
so you just don't like
dive into it and it's like,
what's happening?
And I think just
clearer instructions
with the water placement.
ANDREW GRANT: I see.
OK.
AUDIENCE: The main thing
that we have to do right now
is just the end
game-- making sure
that once you finish
all the mini games,
you have the clues you
need to take it from there.
Then you can have
that conversation.
RIK EBERHARDT: OK.
OK.
ANDREW GRANT: OK.
AUDIENCE: And also art assets.
RIK EBERHARDT: Cool.
ANDREW GRANT: Cool.
I win.
Yay.
All right.
Cool.
So you have three mini games,
and they're, like, doing stuff.
That's good.
All right.
RIK EBERHARDT: Those
are the symptoms.
ANDREW GRANT: Do you
have any-- because it
seems like, for the most part,
these mini games are relatively
simple.
The code is actually not--
RIK EBERHARDT: You're raising--
ANDREW GRANT: Click
the right thing.
You're using assets
because of that.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
ANDREW GRANT: Do you have
any unknown sort of tech-wise
at this point?
You sort of know
everything, or is there--
we're not sure how that works.
that left?
AUDIENCE: So I
don't know how-- I
think something that has been
buggy consistently-- maybe
it's changed now.
I'm not updated on it.
Is the conversation UI?
RIK EBERHARDT: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
We need to iron out a few
bugs with the conversation UI
and make the visual aspect of it
more appropriate with the theme
that we're going
with the assets.
But other than that,
code-wise, there's
just a couple bugs that
won't be hard to fix.
ANDREW GRANT: OK.
All right.
Cool.
AUDIENCE: Yep.
RIK EBERHARDT: So do a glance--
I'm sure you already have.
But make sure that anything that
has any question marks at all
with it gets higher priority.
AUDIENCE: Yep.
ANDREW GRANT: Many not
even finishing it-- right?
Like if it's the case
that you go over the tasks
and you're like, OK.
Now the question marks
are gone, and I'm
comfortable moving it down in
priority, feel free to do that.
But make sure that
those question marks
are done sooner than later.
Because anything that
has a question mark,
it might become
five question marks.
And then you're in trouble.
So just make sure you
look at it seriously
as a high-priority item.
RIK EBERHARDT: When
is sound going in?
AUDIENCE: So we have sound
files in a folder, but, yeah.
They should probably go in.
RIK EBERHARDT: OK.
AUDIENCE: We ended
up-- they were
taking a long time to push.
According to Rachel, they
were taking a long time
to push to our test server.
RIK EBERHARDT: OK.
AUDIENCE: So we just
removed the assets
and just pushed it
without the sound.
RIK EBERHARDT: OK.
AUDIENCE: We do have some sound.
RIK EBERHARDT: All right.
Cool.
ANDREW GRANT: And generally
speaking, sound, much like art,
if the file is the
problem, use a stupid file.
At this stage of
development, it's
more important that
it makes sounds
than it make the right sound.
And so-- again, you
might discover that, oh.
It turns out playing that sound
is harder than we thought,
because we can't
use an Ogg file.
That's the kind of
thing you want to know.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
ANDREW GRANT: But, all right.
Cool.
RIK EBERHARDT: Great.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
RIK EBERHARDT: Thank you.
Have a good holiday.
AUDIENCE: Thank you guys.
You too.
ANDREW GRANT: I think I've
only played the paper version.
AUDIENCE: No, you played
the computer version.
ANDREW GRANT: No, I
did-- way back when.
Way back when, yes I did.
AUDIENCE: You were
our first tester.
ANDREW GRANT: You are so right.
AUDIENCE: Because we have a new
version that we're building up,
and it's still very
broken-- the new one.
RIK EBERHARDT: OK.
ANDREW GRANT: So nothing
more playable than that.
AUDIENCE: Correct.
ANDREW GRANT: OK.
AUDIENCE: Unfortunately.
AUDIENCE: And the minute we
kind of rehauled the system,
the game play's focus
is a lot different.
We cut out a lot of stuff,
and we're focusing more on,
washing your hands is great.
And cholera travels
through water.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
ANDREW GRANT: Good.
RIK EBERHARDT: Is that based
on feedback from Monday,
or this previous lecture?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
That's correct.
We got some very good feedback.
RIK EBERHARDT: Good.
Good, good.
AUDIENCE: It was interesting.
So one of the crucial things
we were wondering about
is we were sort of
designing our game to have
a huge variety of options.
But we recently switched to this
new thing that we really like
a lot, which is that basically
we roll out the mechanics one
by one, so we start
with one build,
using like two or three
[INAUDIBLE]-- maybe only two.
And it actually just is
the case that one of them
is better than the other, right?
Because if the point of the
game is to teach you something,
it's OK if just washing
your hands is [INAUDIBLE]
and something else
is not so great.
Right?
RIK EBERHARDT: Uh huh.
Mhm.
AUDIENCE: And then it
actually slowly becomes
more and more of a game, where
we roll out another village.
And then you have to trade
off balancing your resources.
But then another village appears
upstream of both of them.
And suddenly, the trade-offs
become not so clear.
Where before it
was just one thing
was more price-effective
than another.
Suddenly you
actually have to care
about how infected they are.
Because boiling your
water will reduce
the extent to which you're
infected by upstream water.
And he really liked that as a--
RIK EBERHARDT: So
that's sounds awesome.
How does that get affected by
that change based on the UI
that we saw?
Is it using the same--
AUDIENCE: It's
going to end up up
being the same sort of system.
It's only that the pop-up
screen now eliminates
a bunch of options, because
they aren't necessary anymore.
RIK EBERHARDT: OK.
So these are you removed
a ton of options,
you weren't creating
new options.
AUDIENCE: Correct.
RIK EBERHARDT: That's
what I'm hearing, right?
AUDIENCE: We're basically--
AUDIENCE: We basically
gutted a whole bunch
of the options that
seemed redundant
and apparently weren't helpful
to people on a local scale.
And then we changed
those options
so that they're more distinct.
So while before it was just,
like, the higher magnitude
to price ratio of
affect, now it's
like some things only
really touch infection rate.
Some things just cure people
[INAUDIBLE] infection rate.
RIK EBERHARDT: Cool.
AUDIENCE: And now
you have things
that have that upstream,
downstream play affecting it.
ANDREW GRANT: Exactly.
RIK EBERHARDT: OK.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So the
other crucial thing
we were struggling
with before is
how to make legitimate, actually
meaningful gameplay choices.
When, if you just have
a bunch of options,
there's going to be some static
build-- just the correct one,
right?
So we need to make it so that
it was more situation-dependent.
And [INAUDIBLE] had
a great idea, which
was to be highly effective.
Basically we have a thing
that's the best for reducing
the infection rate
both ways, and then
a thing that's the
best for reducing
the symptom which could
spread infection downstream.
And I think that's the best at
protecting you from infection.
RIK EBERHARDT: Oh, that's great.
AUDIENCE: And then suddenly--
that can be made incredibly
clear to the player, right?
We're not hiding what
the best build is.
ANDREW GRANT: No.
You're playing Rock,
Paper, Scissors,
is what it sounds like.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Exactly.
RIK EBERHARDT: OK.
Awesome.
AUDIENCE: And--
ANDREW GRANT: But-- so
it sounds like UI-wise,
obviously this is a
huge, huge improvement,
just removing the options,
et cetera, et cetera.
But when you start
having a little bit of--
do you already have
cross-talk in your game
code between villages going on?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
We had that previously.
ANDREW GRANT: All right.
So again, it really is you're
actually mostly cutting rather
than adding, it sounds like.
AUDIENCE: Pretty much.
ANDREW GRANT: All right.
Cool.
RIK EBERHARDT: But you are
still adding the new UI--
AUDIENCE: Correct.
Which
RIK EBERHARDT: --which
I imagine we would see.
If we're looking at your backlog
now or soon, a lot of that
would be in the backlog.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
RIK EBERHARDT: Because
I think right now
you've got some very--
actually, go to the task list.
I think this might have
been the vague one.
AUDIENCE: OH, yeah.
The sprint tasklist?
RIK EBERHARDT: Yeah.
Yeah.
That's, like, wicked vague.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
tomorrow, but this
needs to be submitted today.
So you get this really
vague description.
RIK EBERHARDT: Yeah.
We figured that.
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
RIK EBERHARDT: No, that's--
AUDIENCE: It'll probably
be in sprint tasklist five.
I'll outline the stuff
that we're assigned.
RIK EBERHARDT: I don't
care what's in this.
I use what's in this to
know what you're doing.
So I knew exactly
what was going on.
AUDIENCE: So that's fine.
RIK EBERHARDT: That's OK.
AUDIENCE: All right, good.
RIK EBERHARDT: And if you
didn't me in anything,
that's like, OK.
You're really on fire.
ANDREW GRANT: [LAUGH]
RIK EBERHARDT: All right.
Cool.
So Phillip and I were
talking about the UI
that you were doing.
You had mentioned, in the
presentation, civilization.
But Phillip and I-- Phillip
actually remembered this.
If you go to Molleindustria--
Paolo Pedercini
is a serious game designer.
He might hate the
term "serious."
But he made a game
called-- I think it
was called the McDonald's Game?
ANDREW GRANT: I don't know.
RIK EBERHARDT: I think it's
called the McDonald's Game--
again, this is Phillip's idea.
Basically, there's a lot of
different screens going on
in that game.
But if you were to
make your game--
AUDIENCE: Oh, is
it the cutesy one?
RIK EBERHARDT: It
might be, yeah.
PHILLIP TAN: OK.
I know exactly
which one that is.
RIK EBERHARDT: If
your game had as much
UI as one of those working
screens, then you'd be golden.
So that's kind of like a
bar to set yourself towards,
that I think you
could probably match,
especially now that you've
cut a bunch of this stuff.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
ANDREW GRANT: Yeah.
RIK EBERHARDT: But
you can look at that
as yet another way of seeing
how he's putting together
all of these UI
elements, or doing
all of these systemic changes
in this very simple interface.
So take a look at that.
Otherwise, can you go
to the vision statement?
ANDREW GRANT: Yep.
RIK EBERHARDT: So vision
statement-- on Monday,
I asked for you to revise it.
AUDIENCE: Yep.
I have it revised.
I haven't submitted it yet.
RIK EBERHARDT: OK.
Cool.
AUDIENCE: It's right
here on my computer.
RIK EBERHARDT: Great.
Submit it under the
December 10 deadline.
AUDIENCE: OK.
RIK EBERHARDT: And then if you
have a new version afterwards,
submit it there.
And again, the big thing
that I was really looking for
is that 30 seconds of game
play actually reflecting
what the game really is.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: OK.
RIK EBERHARDT: Did you do the--
AUDIENCE: If you want
to read it real quick,
this is what I have now for
the 30 seconds of game play,
if that's better.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
ANDREW GRANT: Yeah.
RIK EBERHARDT: That sounds
like-- well, kind of.
That looks to me like an
overview of a lot of game play.
ANDREW GRANT: More
than 30 seconds.
AUDIENCE: The thing is it was
hard to cut it into 30 seconds,
because if you don't know
the beginning of the game,
then doing 30 seconds in the
middle doesn't make sense,
and doing 30 seconds
in the beginning
doesn't make sense either.
So that's why I kind of like--
ANDREW GRANT: Well, I
might question that.
What is it that you are doing
in 30 seconds in the game-- is
you're probably looking
at one village and saying,
what's the right intervention
for me to do right now?
Can you describe that
experience in a way at all?
AUDIENCE: OK.
ANDREW GRANT: Like I
decide that because there's
nobody downstream, I don't
need to worry about this thing.
So I'm going to just direct
everyone to boil their water.
Like--
AUDIENCE: OK.
I--
ANDREW GRANT: Describe
the thought process.
RIK EBERHARDT: Yeah.
So that might be more like
the major game play concept,
or the vision itself.
ANDREW GRANT: Yeah.
RIK EBERHARDT: [INAUDIBLE].
ANDREW GRANT: That's what
you're doing for the whole game,
absolutely.
You're doing all of that stuff.
RIK EBERHARDT: Yeah.
ANDREW GRANT: But the
30 seconds of game play
is really about what does the
game feel like in the moment?
And it's a planning
game, so it's
hard to do in 30 seconds of
game play that's meaningful.
But--
RIK EBERHARDT: So if Rock,
Paper, Scissors is a way
to synthesize that, or I'm
making choice A versus Choice B
now.
AUDIENCE: Right.
ANDREW GRANT:
Because your game is
about weighing choices
and making a good one.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
ANDREW GRANT: So 30
seconds of game play
should be about making a choice.
AUDIENCE: OK.
ANDREW GRANT: So if what
you have that runs now
is very similar to what I saw
a while ago at this point,
is this backlog up to
date, out of curiosity?
AUDIENCE: So not really.
It still needs to be fixed.
ANDREW GRANT: All right.
AUDIENCE: A lot of this
stuff is like-- [INAUDIBLE].
It's difficult.
ANDREW GRANT: OK.
So--
AUDIENCE: Tasks
have been split up,
and, like, I'm somewhat
removed from the coding.
So I don't actually
know what's being done.
So, for me, it's
hard to edit it.
And so I exactly sure what--
RIK EBERHARDT: Do you have a--
ANDREW GRANT: So I would claim
that not over the holiday.
But, you know, the
priority on Monday
would be to make
sure it is up to date
so you guys know
what's going on.
Because for me
looking at it, hearing
that I can't play a newer
version of the one I
played a while back and seeing
this backlog, I think, uh oh.
So it may be that you're
much better off than that.
But I think your
highest priority task
on, say, Monday is find out
if you're in trouble or not.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
ANDREW GRANT: And
if the answer's we
know we're in trouble, then, OK.
You still need to do it so you
know what trouble you're in
and how to adapt.
Because I don't have
much information,
but I'm a little bit
nervous right now.
But I suspect you're better
off than it looks on that page.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
RIK EBERHARDT: So you have
a one, two, three, four,
five-person coding team?
AUDIENCE: Mhm.
RIK EBERHARDT: Would you say one
person on that team fits lead?
Like, do you have a lead coder?
AUDIENCE: Uh, Harry, probably.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
RIK EBERHARDT: Does
he know he is lead--
AUDIENCE: Harry is
mostly the back end.
I think he does.
Because he mostly
doles-- him and Derek
dole out the tasks,
so I assume they
know that they're the leads.
But--
ANDREW GRANT: OK.
RIK EBERHARDT: Yeah.
Because that could just be you
meeting with them to make it
easier rather than a
full eight-person--
ANDREW GRANT: You might not need
the entire eight-person team
for that.
But again, also
there's a difference
been the person who knows
what the coders are doing
and the person who's
doing the most code.
Those are two different things.
And so you want to
figure out who's
really wearing what hat there.
Yeah.
Cool.
RIK EBERHARDT: Have
we kept you longer?
Thank you.
ANDREW GRANT: Yes.
Thank you for your patience.
RIK EBERHARDT: And, yeah.
ANDREW GRANT: Do you have any
specific sort of questions,
worries that we can try to
talk about, or just get me out
of here.
It's Thanksgiving.
[LAUGH]
AUDIENCE: I don't know.
I think the big unknown for
us right now is the new UI.
We have the mechanics
that we want.
We've really been
playing with the numbers
for a while for what infection
rates and what efficacies
and treatments and
what prices into a--
RIK EBERHARDT: Got it.
AUDIENCE: --beatable game
that's also not trivial.
RIK EBERHARDT: All right.
Cool.
AUDIENCE: So we have that.
The big question is the UI.
The old version of
the UI has all sorts
of problems, where it'll
constantly orphan UI elements,
and they'll sort of
accumulate on the screen.
ANDREW GRANT: Got it Got it.
So it's buggy, among--
AUDIENCE: It's buggy.
So I'm much more worried
about having a functioning UI.
So one thing I'm thinking
about is if we suddenly
find we don't have
anything working
at some point, what sort of
bare-bones UI would work?
Like, for example,
you could concieve--
and this is sort of unclear.
You can see that the UI
can work entirely-- it
would be very, very simple.
It would take half
an hour to write.
For absolutely every
single action in the game,
it's like a keyboard thing.
The four villages are mapped
to the columns Q through Z, W
through X.
ANDREW GRANT: Right.
AUDIENCE: And that
grid of 12 buttons
does every single action.
ANDREW GRANT: Right.
AUDIENCE: So it could
be reduced to that.
It would take a
half hour to write.
ANDREW GRANT: Sure.
AUDIENCE: The question is--
AUDIENCE: That would mean
having to explain that, though.
ANDREW GRANT: Oh, yeah.
RIK EBERHARDT: Yeah.
ANDREW GRANT: So you
can't ship with that.
But it might be worth
doing it, [INAUDIBLE]
half an hour, so you can
test your game as it exists,
internally.
AUDIENCE: There's also
concern whether we--
we're still clear if we have
to-- maybe other people aren't.
But I remember at one
point hearing from you
tablets were what we--
AUDIENCE: We don't need
to worry about that.
RIK EBERHARDT: No, no.
No.
You've got a single platform.
It's what you've
been developing on.
ANDREW GRANT: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: OK.
It's this.
RIK EBERHARDT: It's that.
If that's what you've
been developing on.
ANDREW GRANT: At this
point I would say, yeah.
Whatever's-- we actually want
to grade it on a computer rather
than a tablet.
RIK EBERHARDT: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: OK, good.
RIK EBERHARDT:
That's exactly right.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
RIK EBERHARDT: The tablet
was if it was a challenge
that you wanted to take on.
AUDIENCE: OK, good.
RIK EBERHARDT: The client
was like so, what's the--
AUDIENCE: I totally
misunderstood that.
RIK EBERHARDT: So
the after class life
of this game and the
other Cholera game
is they are being presented
to UNICEF as a possible funder
for games of that nature.
AUDIENCE: OK.
RIK EBERHARDT: So
it's like, you want
to make-- like UNICEF wants
to make games about Cholera
for Ghana, and
you're saying, here
are what those games
might look like.
Here are prototypes.
AUDIENCE: OK.
RIK EBERHARDT: These
are not the games
we're going to ship to you.
And if they were going to be the
games-- so when we're setting
one of these games,
we're going to be saying,
imagine this is a
tablet-style game.
AUDIENCE: OK.
RIK EBERHARDT: And
the other thing
is if you are graduating and
wanted to work on this project,
and [INAUDIBLE] had
funding for that project,
they might hire the students
who worked on these games
to make that project.
ANDREW GRANT: Sure.
RIK EBERHARDT: That's very
much a talk-in-January kind
of thing.
AUDIENCE: Right.
RIK EBERHARDT: Yeah.
ANDREW GRANT: And so
generally speaking, if that
takes a big worry of the UI
off your shoulders, awesome.
But regardless, if you have
an unknown like that-- like,
as the new UI.
Is that a big question mark?
I'd make sure you schedule
it, prioritize it higher.
It sounds like you have your
game play under control,
which is awesome.
But you want to make sure
that whatever unknowns
you have are scheduled sooner so
that if they go horribly awry,
you have time to
adapt to that problem.
RIK EBERHARDT:
And my last one is
going to be, you've
already cut a lot.
Can you cut more?
When you meet on Monday and
you say, are you in trouble?
Like, all right.
You've proved you can
cut a bunch of stuff.
You could possibly
cut a little bit more
out of it too-- assuming
it's the kind of cutting
that doesn't create new work.
ANDREW GRANT: Right.
But I would start with
that-- where the heck are we,
if you don't know.
RIK EBERHARDT: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: OK.
ANDREW GRANT: And
probably all eight of you
don't know where you are, so
it's worth getting all eight
of you to know where you are.
AUDIENCE: I can't
even-- I see such-- I
see resulted-- I
didn't even realize
[INAUDIBLE] until I forgot it.
ANDREW GRANT: [LAUGH]
And that's why the last
project is so tough, actually.
RIK EBERHARDT: It doesn't fit
the school year very well.
ANDREW GRANT: Yeah.
Unfortunately it's a shorter
term than we'd like to have,
but, yeah.
Eight people's a lot to keep
organized, even with full time.
AUDIENCE: We only have seven.
Don't worry.
There's no eighth person.
ANDREW GRANT: [LAUGH]
RIK EBERHARDT: OK, cool.